(upbeat music)
- Try to get it off of me.
Get it off of me, what is this?
This is not even
my shampoo again.
Hi, my name is Arturo Castro,
I play Jamie, hello everybody.
This is the bedbugs episode.
I've just been in a shower
with all my clothes on.
- [Director] Alright,
let's start the water,
let's roll sound.
- [Arturo] Whoo!
Bring it baby!
We have bedbugs! (screaming)
- Directing Hannibal,
Arturo and Abby, to me,
if I'm not in the
scene, it's so much fun,
and it's just play, it's
just so fun and play.
But being in the scene, I
felt very self-conscious
because you can't even
filter your thoughts.
I felt like I was
like "Totally dude.",
Okay, let me just do that again,
"Totally, dude.", Okay now
have him like, turn to me.
It's like you seem
like a crazy person.
Great.
- Cool.
- Well, I wanted to do
one more, like smaller.
- Maybe we got them from Abby.
- (gasps) Don't you dare
bring her into this!
- This is the first season
I think you see them
actually get into an
argument over the bed bugs.
- That was like an
overnight, just him and me,
scene after scene after scene.
I went nuts, I was like
a maniacal monster.
- But it was like the right,
- The vibe.
- What are you a fucking dog?
- Are you? I dunno.
- A fucking rat?
- It's really exciting because
even when they're fighting,
they're still fighting
as really like family,
you know what I mean? (laughs)
Until you mention Abby, and
then you get a slap in the face.
I might have gone too far.
Broad City was my first
big gig, you know.
And after that other
stuff has come but,
I haven't found
the sense of family
or sense of belonging like I
do here, you know what I mean?
I don't know man, I feel like
the luckiest man in the world.
Just kill me now,
just fucking do it.
Just kill me, just kill me now.
(upbeat music)